(cheerleaders talking over each other)
- Jumps are the prettiest
thing that a cheerleader can do
and just one part can mess it up.
Once I throw her, I'm
just like, okay that's it.
I'm not scared anymore, she's
already up there, I got it.
Performing and taking a
test, it's all the same.
I practice and practice and practice it,
and I still don't feel as if
I got it, I practice more.
I feel like there is no reason to go
if you're not going to give it your all.
I love it when the girls get so frustrated
to the point where they're
mad at theirselves.
Like I just want to walk
away, like it's all too much.
But then it's like no, no, no, no,
you can't quit, like I'm
not gonna let you give up
because you didn't let me give up.
There's always more that you
can do, there's always better.
It's a rush at the same time,
it's just like you got
it, you remember this,
you've done this before.
Once we get it set,
then I'm like okay, it's go time.
(energetic electronic music)